In this course you'll learn how to solve
10 Very popular coding interview problems,
and you'll learn the theory behind the solutions,
so you'll be better equipped to solve other types
of problems as well. We'll come to the 10
popular coding interview problems course 10
well chosen problems that cover different
algorithms and data structures topics
to increase your knowledge
and prepare for interviews.
Please try to solve before watching the solution
prepare yourself and see you in the first lecture
Welcome to this video, where we will solve
the first problem of this course valid anagram
acquired easy problem compared to Knucks wants we
are given two strings s one and S two and we are
asked to check if their anagrams. Two strings are
anagrams if they're made of the same characters
with the same frequency just in a different order.
For example, with a string standard and garden,
we take one of them will rearrange its
characters and we get the other one.
How are we going to solve this problem? We know
the two strings are anagrams if they have the
same characters with the same frequency. So what
we can do is to calculate the frequency of each
character and as one, calculate the frequency of
each character in s two and compare the results.
But what structure do we use to do so we can use
an array where each cell represents the number
of frequencies, they all start at zero, then for
each character in the string will increment the
corresponding cell. This solution is suitable
when the alphabet is small, while the number of
possible characters is not big. For example,
if the strings can only be made of lowercase
alphabetical letters, would need an array of 26
elements, it's fine. But it's not necessarily
the case. They can contain all the characters.
And we have 1000s and 1000s of existing possible
characters, the array would take a lot of
time and space to create it and traverse it.
The best structure for our problem is the hash
table structure that maps unique keys to values.
In our case, the key will be the coke
to other values number of occurrences.
For example, if you have nameless and salesman
whose name was we get this hash table.
And the salesman we get this one. Do they have the
same keys with the same values so they're equal?
It means that nameless and salesmen are anagrams.
Encode who first showed that both strings
have the same length, because if they're not,
it's impossible for them to be anagrams. Then who
grid our two hash tables, and we start to our C
for each character and as one if the key is
already existing. And for one who does increment
else, we created a new set its value to one than
for us to same logic, but with freq. Two. And
now that we filled them with each other, they
have the same values. For each cane frog one,
if it doesn't exist in frog two, or for
quality isn't able to frog to off key,
return false. It means that either the character
of us one doesn't exist in our stew, or they don't
appear the same number of times after the loop,
if we didn't find any difference, we return true.
And in Python, we don't ever need to
write all this because we have a class
named counter in collections module that builds
the table of occurrences just by passing the
string as an argument. And we can compare
dictionaries with the equality operator.
So in reality, who does return count
off as one equal to count off as two.
For the time complexity, in the worst case, as
well as to have the same length. Let's name it
as we're traversing N characters at most three
times, and Sujan. Inserting in a hash table
costs are one in average, got off, amp was off and
was off and we'll give some of amp on complexity.
And for the space complexity, we have an hour
for each table because they can contain up to n
keys each we got an often space complexity.
We still have another solution to discuss.
You have to know the two anagrams how
the same lexicographically sorted string,
for example, with nameless and salesman. If we
sold nameless, we get a ELMN s s. I will salesman
same thing. So in the second solution, who
do salt posturings and compare the results
in code, after the equal condition,
returns sorted as one is equal to sorted
as two. But sorting a string of characters
because of n log n time we're doing it twice
was after comparing. We've got an off n log n
time complexity. And for the space complexity,
we have often for the sorted result twice,
we'll get an off air space complexity.
Who's the end of this video? whistle
the valid underground problem,
I hope that you understood the ball
solutions and seen the next one
Welcome back to the course in this lecture
rule. So the first and last position problem,
you are given a sorted array of integers are an
integer target. And we're asked to find the index
of the first and last position of target and our
if Target can't be found in our return minus one
minus one. For example, if our is 245-555-5799,
and target is five, the author's would be to six
because the first position of target
is to, and his last position is six.
First of all, because the array is sorted,
all the elements with the same value will
be ages into each other. For example, here all
positions of the value five are consecutive.
It means that the first possible solution is to
start traversing the array from the beginning
for the first position of target, and keep
walking until finding the last position.
With our example, we have two four,
then five who found the first position
we can walk in, we have 5555. This one is the
last one, we found the N position, we turn them
in code, we start traversing indexes of our and if
our phi is equal to target, it means that we found
the start position. Now we keep walking while the
next element exists and is equal to target y plus
one is smaller than length of our and our five
plus one is equal to target increment i. After
the while loop. INR represents the position of
the last occurrence. This is why we return start i
and if the fall ends without
having returned the result,
it means that we didn't find target in
our at all return minus one minus one.
Know that it's possible to have sought position
equal to and position it happens when there
is only one occurrence of targeting our for
the time complexity on target exists, which
covers the part befores first position, third
sequence of occurrences and where it doesn't,
which covers a whole array. In both cases, which
covers almost add elements, where n is the number
of elements of our we've got a time complexity
of add a cost and space complexity because
we're just using n variables. This solution uses
linear sir, to give an off on time complexity.
Both the resorted so we can think of using binary
search. Let's try to use binary search to find the
start position. With binary search, you can find
the position of an element in a sorted array.
But here, we're not searching for any position
of target, we're searching for the first one.
R is the first position of target
if r is equal to target, obviously,
but also r of i minus one has to be smaller
than target smaller because the array is sorted.
So we will use binary search normally, but
to add a second condition before returning.
Let's try it with our example. Left and right
solid first and last element of our as usual.
Man, his left password divided by two, we get four
here is true that our four is equal to target,
but it's not enough our four minus one is
not smaller than target. So med is not the
starting position of target. But should you
go to the left part or to the right part now,
our have made is not created on target. So the
first position can only be in the left part
we continue made is now zero plus
three divided by two we get one,
our phone is smaller than target. So the starting
position can only be in the right part we continue
made is now two plus three divided by two which is
to have meat is equal to target and our male minus
one is smaller than target. So meta represents
the first position of target, we return it.
In code, we're going to first have an early
exit condition for the case where the first
element is equal to target with DACA know that
zero is the starting position returned zero.
By the way, in solutions based on binary
search, put as much early exit conditions
as possible to handle edge cases
and avoid out of bounds problems.
After it we initialize left and right
at zero and minus one respectively.
Zero and r minus one are the indexes of the
first and last element of R. Now while of is
smaller than or equal to right, we calculate mid
index is left plus rho divided by two. Afterward,
we have three cases the case where both conditions
are respected. where alpha is equal to target on
our beta minus one is smaller than target. It
means that made is a sort of position we turn it
second case are made is smaller than
target. It means that we're still before
the starting point. position. This is why we
take left and mid plus one to start again in
the right part. Else, it means that we exceeded
the consecutive sequence, or we're excited but
not other beginning. So start can only be in the
left part, we take rato mid minus one of the wall
didn't return the result is means the target
doesn't have an existing our return minus one.
Now we found this thought in the experts,
we still need to find the end index,
we can think of just walking starting from
start until we find the last position of target.
But it would ruin everything we
did, because in the worst case,
we need to traverse the whole array, which
results in an old Anton complexity same as
the first solution you guys did to find the
end index, we will also use binary search.
But the condition is a bit different from the
first time when searching for the start position
are of men how to be equal to target and our male
minus one smaller than target. And for the end
position, our med has to be equal to target and
our mid plus one has to be greeted on target.
Next element has to be greater because it
would mean that from the right, we're not
in consecutive Target Elements anymore, so the
actual position is the last position of target.
In code, we just change a few things, the only
exit condition occurs now when the last element
is equal to talk, it means that the last position
of target is in the last index of our n minus one
without a return. Then in the three cases, the
cases where we will turn mid is when our made is
equal to target, and our met plus one is greater
than target. For the two remaining ones, he won
our main is greater than target, then we exceeded
the consecutive sequence, we'll go to the left
part, right becomes mere minus one else, it means
that either will be for the consecutive sequence
or incited but not at the end, so and can only
be in the right part, left becomes mid plus one.
Now we have our fine salt function,
we have our Find and function,
we can move to the main solution function. First
of all, we have some early exit conditions,
who can identify at least three cases
where we can't find target role.
When the array has no elements, one target is
smaller than the first element. And when target
is greater than the last element in the last two
ones. Because the array is sorted, who can deduce
the target is not equal to all other elements. If
at least one of these conditions is true, without
the return minus one minus one health who co
found sought to give the stock position we
call font and to find the end position and wait
on start. And if Target doesn't exist in our
sorted annual have returned minus one
bath, we still got the expected result.
For the time complexity, we're using binary
search twice. And binary search has an
awful lot and time complexity because
we keep dividing the input size by two,
two times of work and gives us
all of log n time complexity.
Add for the space complexity, you'll get all
one because we're just using eight variables.
Before ending this lecture, I want to tell you
that if you're not comfortable with binary search,
you should really work on it because
it's a fundamental algorithm technique
that appears in many problems on this one, find
peek first bad version, and many other ones.
Lose Hello this lecture, I hope that you
understood the solutions and seen the next one.
Welcome back to the course in this lecture, we
will solve the cliff largest element problem,
you are given an array of integers and
an integer k. And we're asked to find
the K eighth largest element. For example,
if you have are equal to four to 9756713
and k equal to four, the output would be
six because the largest element is nine,
the second largest is seven, the third
largest is seven and the fourth largest is six
Firstpost possible solution that we may think of
is to remove the maximum element k minus one times
because after doing so, the next maximum
represents the K eighth largest element.
For example with our array K is four. So
we remove the maximum element three times
first iteration Max is mine we remove it, second
iteration Max is seven we move it third iteration
Max is seven we remove it now that we finished
the three iterations the maximum in the remaining
elements is the fifth largest element of the
original array, it six here who returned it.
In code, we have a follow various repeated k
minus one times one remove the maximum element
after the loop, return max of all But for the
time complexity suited for the maximum cost of n,
where n is the number of elements and removing
it from the array cost, and in the worst case,
because we may need to shift all the n minus
one elements, and our loop is repeated k minus
one times we'll have k minus one times to add,
plus add for finding the final largest element.
In total, we have k minus one times two n
plus n, which is two times k times n minus n,
which gives us off k times our time complexity,
where n is the number of elements of our
own, although in reality during the
iterations, and will decrease because
we have less and less elements, but we get the
sample complexity. And for the space complexity,
we're not using input size related variables,
we have a constant space complexity.
This solution is a bit slow. Let's move to the
next one. The idea of the second solution is to
start by sorting the array because by doing so, we
know that the largest element is other last cell,
the second largest element just before it, the
third largest just before it, and so on with our
array was sorted, and k is four. So return
the fourth element starting from the end,
in a gentle way, we sold our and we turn our
n minus k, and minus k represents the index
of the key elements starting from the end. For
the time complexity, we have both analog and for
sorting the array and all one for accessing,
we've got an O of n log n time complexity.
And for the space complexity, it depends on
the space complexity or the sorting function.
This solution is way faster than the first
one except in some cases, but we still have
an all the solution to discover. In the first
solution we didn't have to solve to it is good,
but searching for the maximum cost at each
iteration, which slows down the process.
What if instead of getting the maximum cost log
out only yours is possible by using a priority
queue. A priority queue is a queue where the next
element to be popped is not the first one that
entered with the one with the highest priority.
And it's usually implemented with a heap. If you
don't know about heaps, and priority queues,
you should really watch my YouTube video on
the subject, you will find the link below or you
can just search for inside code heaps on YouTube.
And after building our priority queue, popping
the next element because of work out holy,
so we just have to pay the cost of
building the priority queue, which is add.
For example, with our array, this is what our
heap would look like, you can see that the element
at the top is the greatest one who extracted
and it costs of work and to rearrange notes.
second iteration will extract the root cause
of work and to rearrange to maintain the order.
third iteration, same thing. Now that we do the k
minus one iterations, the next extracted node is
the eighth largest element, we'll turn it here
it's six. In Python, we have the hip Q module
with a problem is that it's implemented with a
min heap, not a max heap. So the top will find
the smallest element not the greatest to counter
that will just multiply values by minus one to
reverse the order. So we start by replacing our by
minus ln for each element in our after doing so,
we heapify our to make it respect to heap
property. And now we really do start extracting,
we extract from it k minus one times. After
the loop, we extract the last time and return
the result multiplied by minus one, obviously,
to get the original number though was in our,
for the time complexity, who have earned to build
a new array with reverse values, and to heapify
it, go check the video to know why. And then
we have k minus one iterations, each iteration
because of work and to extract after the loop,
we have all worked out to extract one more time.
In total, we have two n plus k minus one times
log n plus log n, which is two n plus k log n,
which gives a time complexity of of amples k
log n, which is a bit better than the one of
the previous solution, because k can't exceed
add. For this solution, stop giving interesting
time performance difference only when n is
huge and case small. Because when k is close
to an off campus, k log n is close to O of n log
n, the time complexity of the previous solution.
Pause When k is close to zero, O of n plus k log
n is close to O of n for the space complexity
who have unfold the priority queue who got an
offer and space complexity. We reached the end
of this video I hope that you understood the
three solutions and see what the next one will
come back to the course in this lecture we will
solve the symmetric tree problem. We have a binary
tree and we want to see if it's symmetric.
In other words, if it's a mirror of it Self.
For example, this tree is symmetric, because
if we take his left part, reverse it, who that
is right part. And vice versa, if we take its
right part, we reverse it who got his left part.
But this one is not symmetric. For example, if
we reverse its left part, we don't get the right
part. Okay how to solve this problem? To check
if a tree is symmetric, what we really need
to check is that left and right sub trees are
symmetric to each other. Who will focus on that
you need to know that for tree problems,
the solution is usually don't coercively
we process the root, then we call the function
on both sub trees and we combine the results.
For example, to get the sum of elements of a
binary tree, we have the value of the root,
then recursively call the function on both
sub trees to get the sum of their elements.
After doing so, we return root value plus some of
left subtree plus some of right subtree. This way
of traversing is called depth first search, and
it's how we solved the majority of tree problems.
Let's go back to our problem, we have two
trees, route one and route two and want
to check if they're symmetric to each other.
First case, both trees are empty. In that case,
we return true because they're still symmetric
to each other, there is nothing that breaks the
condition. Second case, won't we exist,
but the other one doesn't. In that case,
without let it use it and not symmetric
because the node of the tree that exists
doesn't even exist in the other
one, it's empty, we return false.
Third case, both trees exist, but the
roots don't have the same value. Here also,
they're not symmetric, because in symmetric
trees, the roots must have the same value,
because when we reverse the tree, the root
position doesn't change. And last case, both trees
exist, and they have the same root value. In this
case, we still can say that they're symmetric,
because Okay, the roots have the same value.
But we still need to check their sub trees,
having the same root value is not
enough to serve their symmetric.
And if we take two symmetric trees, we can
notice that they have the same root value,
though the left subtree of the first one is
symmetric to the right subtree of the second one,
and on the right subtree of the first one is
symmetric to the left subtree of the second one.
We verified that root values are equal. So
we need to try the remaining two conditions.
And how are we going to do so we're going to do
so recursively, because if you think about it,
we're building a function that checks
if two binary trees are symmetric,
which is exactly what we need. This
is why we'll use the same function.
It may sound hard to understand,
but this is what recursion about
a function calling itself. If you're not familiar
with recursion, you should really have a look at
it before continuing this course because
we will use it again in a further problem.
If you want to learn recursion, you come
to the course I made on the subject.
It's a complete and well appreciated course
that will let you be comfortable with recursion.
Let's go back to our problem. We saw that we use
the function we're making, we saw that we use the
function we're making. We call it on route one
dot left and route two dot right we're called
on route 1.1 and route dot left and we tell you
at both calls return true, it means that both
conditions are verified, the left subtree of route
one is symmetric to the right subtree of route
to other the rights of drove route one is
symmetric to the left of Jove route two.
Let's quickly see an example. We want
to check if this tree is symmetric,
so we check if it's sub trees
are symmetric to each other.
They have the same root value, so we check the
left subtree of root one with white socks off root
two, same root value, who took the left subtree
of root one with right subtree of root two, same
root value, we check left and right, same root
value. Other children are both normal they will
turn true. Same with value and symmetric children.
All conditions are respected, it returns true.
Now right up to a fruit one with lots of to
fruit two, they have the same root value.
Their children on both know both calls
return true. All conditions are respected.
The caller turns true. Back to here, all
conditions are respected. The Colita is true.
Now REITs offshore foot one with Latakia for
two, they don't have the same root value,
the call returns false. Not all conditions
are respected. The call returns false.
Who don't ever need to check the second call
because we already have a non respected condition.
The call returns false. The initial call
return false so our tree is not symmetric.
In code, let's first make our our symmetric
function. It takes two trees as parameter
route one and route two. First case
both don't exist without Q two and true.
Second case, one of them exists but the other
one doesn't. Third case, they have a different
root value. In both of these cases, the
trees are not symmetric, so return false
will write, if root one is non is not equal
to root two is non, or root one dot val is
not equal to root two, that wall will
return false. And now in the last case,
both trees exist and have the same root
value, we still need to Chuck's up trees,
which are that would wander I'd love to see much
to root to the droid. And that root wonder tried
is symmetric to root to the left, we do so by
recursively, calling the function twice. Once with
root one dot left and root two dot right and once
with root one or twice and route two dot left,
both of them need to return true. So we turn
the results combined with the Add operator.
And now when our main solution function is
symmetric, we first check that the input
tree exists because if it doesn't, we cannot
return true, an empty tree is symmetric. Else,
whichever is sub trees are symmetric to
each other with the function who made Now
we return our symmetric Rudolph left and rudos.
Right. That's it. For the time complexity,
we're just performing a depth first
search traversal of the input tree
and the first cause of anti m
where n is the number of nodes.
And for the space complexity, a symmetric tree
has to be balanced. And the call stack size
needed by a recursive function that traverses a
balanced binary tree is an awful look at who got
an off walk and space complexity. That's it for
this lecture, we've seen an interesting problem
on trees. I hope that you have been able to
understand the solution seen with the next lecture
Welcome back to the course in this lecture, we
will solve the Generate parenthesis problem,
a problem that we will solve using backtracking.
By the way, in this course, I try to include
problems on different pattern spire research
hash table backtracking, depth, first search,
and so on. But one problem and each is not enough.
This is why you need to study more problems.
For that, I suggest you to have a look at my
50 popular coding interview problems course.
It contains 50 Problems different from the ones
in this course, about many data structures and
algorithmic techniques, you can have a look at
the curriculum and reviews on the main page.
Anyway, let's go back to our problem. We
are given an integer n and we're asked
to generate all valid combinations of N pairs of
parenthesis. For example, with an equal to three,
here are all the valid combinations. First of
all, what does a vowel combination mean and how
to check if a combination is valid. A combination
that contains one type of paranthesis is valid.
If every opening parenthesis has its closing
parenthesis, and it doesn't have a closing
parenthesis without having an end used opening
parenthesis before it. Let's see some examples.
This combination is invalid because these opening
parenthesis don't have closing parenthesis
the syntax is invalid. Second example
this combination is invalid because we
have a closing parenthesis without an
end use opening parenthesis before it.
Last example, this one is valid because each
opening parenthesis has its closing one,
and there is no closing parenthesis
without an unused opening one before it.
Now how to check if a combination is valid. To do
so we can maintain a stack where we push one we
find an opening parenthesis and we pop one and
find the closing one. The condition is that we
don't try to pop from the stack when it's empty,
or the stack has to be empty after we finish
traversing the combination. Trying to perform
the stock one is empty means that we have a
closing parenthesis without an available opening
one before it all ones what we found before have
been popped by all the closing parentheses. And
the second condition is that the stock must be
empty at the end. Because still having elements
in the stack after traversing means that we have
opening parenthesis that didn't gather closing one
yet. In both cases, the combination is not valid.
And because we have only one
type of parenthesis around once,
we don't ever need the stock, who can do is use
a variable div that represents the difference
between the number of opening parenthesis and the
number of closing once. It has to be zero the end
and if it becomes negative during
the process, then it's not valid.
Okay, but what's the relation with backtracking?
In this problem, we're not asked to check if a
combination is valid. We're asked to generate
all valid combinations of N pairs. And we use
backtracking because at each step of building the
combination, we have two possibilities, adding an
opening parenthesis and adding a closing one. And
because we want all combinations, we try them both
because we get new ones want to add an opening
one, and all the ones want to add a closing one.
Also in backtracking. We can have a
condition where we backtrack With continuing,
it's one we know that the actual branch won't
lead us to a valid solution. In our case,
it's one death becomes negative, it means that
the combination we built until now isn't valid,
it's useless to continue building it, we know
that it won't give us a valid combination. Anyway.
Let's see an example. With n equal to
three, we'll get this recursion tree.
If you're wondering why our sauce at six is
because the n given us input represents the
number of pairs. And in n pairs, we have two
advantages. So we multiply by two because we're
adding one parenthesis by level one, we go to
the left to add an opening one and increment div.
And when we go to the right to add
a closing one, and decrement, if
we can notice that we have branches
that have been stopped earlier,
those are branches were diff becomes
negative. As soon as they've becomes negative,
we stop also Evon with branches that created the
combination of N pairs, we don't take all of them,
we take only those who are divisible to zero,
remember the validity condition. So at the end,
here are the combinations that get
added to our combinations array.
Encode who stopped by creating a recursive
function rack that will fill the combinations
array, it takes us parameters and the
number of remaining parentheses to add,
def the difference between opening and closing
brackets COMM The actual combination that we're
building, and comps theory of combinations, the
one that we're searching for in our problem.
The first base case is one difficult negative, hit
it with Dr. Batra Kodaka return to go back to the
previous call. The second base case is one we've
been able to add all the parenthesis we've been
able to build a combination. But in this case,
we don't automatically add it to our comps array,
we first check if d f is equal to zero. Remember
the condition. So if f is zero, we draw the
parenthesis of our combination to form a string
and we add it to our valid combinations array.
Else, we have the recursive case, we
said that we have two possibilities,
adding an opening parenthesis and adding a closing
one. Therefore, who will have two recursive calls.
For the first one, we add an opening parenthesis
to our combination, then when we call and becomes
n minus one because we have one less parent is
to add and this becomes the plus one because
remember that to add one one will add an opening
parenthesis. After the call, we move the opening
one we added to put a closing one. After doing
so we call the function again. But this time
diff becomes diff minus one. Remember that we
subtract one when we add a closing parenthesis.
And after the call, we remove the parenthesis
we added to backtrack to the previous call.
And we made our function. By the way, we can ever
optimize a little bit by dotclear. Returning if
div is greater than add because if is the case,
it means that we don't have enough remaining
parenthesis to close all our opening parenthesis.
div is greater than n. So we just return.
If you're confused about what's happening
here, have a look again other recursion tree.
And most importantly, you should learn
more about recursion and backtracking.
The method we're using here to
generate all possible combinations,
it's common to a lot of problems, you
should really be comfortable with it.
Now in the main solution function, we'll first
create an array comps where we will put our valid
combinations and we call our QC function to fill
it. But the tricky part here is that we pass two
times n as an argument not add, because the n
given as input represents the number of pairs,
nor the number of parenthesis and a pair is
made of two parentheses. So we pass two times,
our combinations will be of length two
times. After filling comps, we just return it
for the time complexity. In the worst case, what
add a zero, we have a cost of an to join the
parenthesis we write T of zero is equal to add
n in the recursive case, and again moving from
the combination cost of one, but we have two
calls where the input size gets reduced by one
and is becoming added minus one in total t of n
is equal to two times u of r minus one plus one.
Now we keep replacing t of n is equal to two times
t of n minus one plus one. So T of N minus one is
equal to two times t of n minus two plus one we
replace or simplify and we got four times two
and minus two plus three. We replace again, t of
n minus two is two times two of Armani three plus
one will replace will simplify and we get
eight times T of animal is three plus seven.
This recurrence relation is a common one we can
already notice the drill form. It's t of n is it
To power k times t of n minus k plus two power k
minus one, we have the value of T of zero, so we
need to find the value of K to go to T of zero
and minus k equal to zero. So k is equal to n,
where plus k by n, who got t of n is equal to two
power n times T of zero plus to power n minus one.
We know that T of zero is earned workplace,
we got t of n is equal to two power n times
n plus two power n minus one would give us
an O of n times two power n time complexity.
Know that here and represents the length
of the combination, which is two times
the number of pairs given us input. Also,
n times two power n is not the exact power,
the number of operations will be less than that
do two branches where we backtrack earlier,
O of n times two power n would be the exact
bound if we had no condition on our combinations.
If you don't know the technique are used to find
the time complexity over this recursive function.
It's called the substitution method, it's an
important technique to know you should learn
about it. And for the space complexity, we have
n plus one for the cost like size, the length
of the longest branch in the recursion tree. But
we also need to count the required space to store
the combinations. The length of a combination
is at and it has two possible characters. So
we have two power and possible combinations.
And the length of each one of them is n. So we
need n times two power n space to solve them. We
got off on times to power and space complexity.
But not all of them are valid, we will
need way less than n times to power n,
n times two power n is just an upper bound. And
we all t the required space for combinations
is n times the number of elements after
filling the comms array. We reached the end
of this lecture, I hope that you understood this
backtracking solution and see you in the next one.
Welcome back to the course in this lecture
rules or the gas station problem are given
a circle a list of gas stations where we can
go from Station II to the station i plus one,
and the last one goes back to the first one.
And we are asked to find the index of the station
from where we start to be able to traverse all the
stations and go back to the initial one without
running out of gas. Know that we can only move
forward the gas tanks thought empty gas of i
represents the amount of gas at the station i
cost of iron presents the cost to go from the
station out to the next one, the answer is
guaranteed to be unique. And if the station we're
searching for doesn't exist return minus one we
did use or there will be at most one station
for more we can traverse and be able to go back.
For example, if we have these 10 stations, the
output is eight because when we start from station
eight, we can go back to it without running out
of gas. We start with no gas, as mentioned the
the problem, we add for gas of station eight and
we pay one to move to the next station, who add
five gas of station line and we pay two to move
to the next station, we add one and pay five who
add five and pay two, or three and pay two, or
three and pay eight, we add five and pay two,
or three and pay for we add one and pay two, or
three and pay five, and we've been able to go back
to station eight, you could see that the amount of
gas never became negative. Which is not the case
for Office stations, for example with station one
who add five and pay two, or three and pay two,
or three. And if you pay the eight to move to the
next station, the amount of gas becomes negative,
which means that we can't continue, the
station we started from is not the right one.
Let's solve this problem. A brute force solution
of a darkly comes in our mind is to simply
simulate what happens with every station and we
find one that respects the condition who turn its
index. Let's try it with our example. With the
first one, we add one with a five and the cost
becomes negative Dr eliminated. Next one, we add
five and P two we have three and PE two, we have
three and PE eight air the amount of remaining
gas became negative not this one. Next one, three
and PE two we have three NP eight and remaining
became negative. Next one, we have three NP eight
remaining became negative. Next one, we add five
and pay two or three and pay for we add one and
pay two or three and pay five and remaining became
negative not this one. Next one, we add three and
pay for negative. Next one, we add one and pay
to negative next one who has three and pay five
negative next one who have plus four minus one
plus five minus two plus one minus five plus five
minus two plus three minus two plus three minus
eight. was four minus two, plus three minus four,
plus one minus two plus three minus five.
And we've been able to go back to the station
from where we started without the alternate
because we know that the answer is unique.
In code, we create a function that takes
us parameters, the array gas theory, cost,
and index of the station form where we thought
the goal of this function is to tell us if we can
finish the cycle by starting from the stations
thought, we first need a variable remaining
that source the remaining amount of gas, we also
need the variable to store our actual position.
Our initial position is the station FOMO,
we thought so initialize our add start.
And we also need a boolean variable started
to know who started walking yet or not,
we need this variable in our loop condition. We
need to keep looping until we go back to start,
we write why isn't equal to start or not
started. Here not started is important,
because if we don't use it, we won't even enter
the loop. Remember that I initialize a stock.
So I installed our equal, we want them to
be equal. But after traversing the cycle,
not now this is why we need the variable started
to know if we're in the case, where is equal to
start, because we didn't start yet. Or because
we traverse a cycle, and I went back to start.
Let's continue inside the loop we saw started to
true because we started then we update remaining.
We saw that on the station i We are the amount of
gas in it, and we pay the cost to move to the next
one. So we add gas of our answer drug costs of I.
After doing that, if we mainly becomes negative,
it means that we couldn't go back to salt, we
don't have enough gas, we return false, else,
we move to the next station. The next station is
usually i plus one. But we need to add modules
the number of stations to handle the case were of
the last station i becomes i plus one add modules
and it goes back to zero, we right i becomes
a plus one modules the number of stations.
And if we finish the loop, it means that we've
been able to go back to start return true.
Now in our main solution function, we just
tried the function we made on each station
as we did in the example. And we turn the actual
station as soon as the function returns true.
And if the function fails with all stations
will to n minus one for the time complexity,
because the answer is unique. A
possible worst case is this one,
because by starting from station zero, which
covers n stations before getting a negative amount
from station one, which covers n minus one from
station two, which covers n minus two, and so on,
we get the sum n plus n minus one plus n minus
two and so on until one. After simplifying,
we found that it's an O of n squared, we'll
get an O of n squared time complexity,
or the constant space complexity because
we're not using input size related variables
of n squared is low. For this problem, we're
getting off n squared because for each station,
we're traversing again, almost all the stations,
let's see how to optimize it. The main thing that
you need to understand for the second solution
is that if we start from the station or the index
thought and reach a negative amount of the station
I then all stations between Staten Island clauses
are not valid. We don't need to try them with
Dr. John to Iboss one. Let me tell you why. We
have the case where gas of thought is smaller
than cost of start. He the loop stops darkly
because remaining becomes negative, it stops us
thought so there are no other stations involved.
Nothing to talk about here. But when gusoff Start
is greater than or equal to cost of salt, the loop
moves to all the stations, it can traverse a bunch
of stations before remaining becomes negative.
For example, here when we start at station four,
remaining becomes negative at index seven. It
means the stations 456 and seven are all invalid.
We'll start again from purpose one, eight. But why
girls will start is greater than or equal to cost
of start. In our case, the difference is three.
Every three is considered as an advantage over
starting from next stations is like a bonus by
starting from station four. We have three more gas
and installing from the next one, station five.
And even with that bonus, we didn't have enough
gas to do a full cycle. We stopped at station
seven avenue that bonus we couldn't go over
station seven. So how do you want to go over
it without a bonus? It's like you have $500 and
they aren't enough to buy a particle PC. Then you
say this $500 weren't enough. I'll try with four
hundreds maybe they will be enough. It's a logical
and this is why when remaining becomes negative.
We don't try again from the station that comes
after The one where we started, who skipped all
the ones who traversed we started going from IPOs.
With our example, who start from the beginning, we
may name becomes negative who's taught from IPOs
one at five and we pay two remaining becomes three
who are three, we pay two remaining becomes four,
who else we pay eight remaining becomes minus
one negative. What we're going to do now is to
dock the start again from here, without
trying again, from stations to three,
who add follow up to remaining becomes three, who
else we will pay for remaining become Sue, who
add one who pay two remaining becomes one who
has free will by five remaining becomes minus one
negative. Once again, without his thought, again,
from i plus one, we add four we pay one remaining
becomes three who add four who pay two remaining
becomes six, and we finish traversing the array,
the candidate is station eight. But it doesn't
mean that it can do a full cycle, it just means
that we can reach the end of the array without
reaching a negative amount of gas. We didn't check
the pot before it. This is why I said candidate.
It's a potential valve station. We don't know yet.
To say that a candidate station
is valid by starting from their
remaining Miss never become negative one
traversing the path from candidate to the end.
But also when traversing the path from the
beginning of the array to candidate X clause.
The first part of the cycle is what we verified
during the traversal. And for the second part of
the cycle, we just calculated the sum of gas from
zero to candidate minus the sum of costs from zero
to candidate, the result represents the remaining
gas after traversing that pot. And if by adding
it to remaining the result stays positive, then
candidate is a valid station. Else we have no
valid station. For example, here the sum of
gas from zero to candidate exclusive is 24.
The sum of course from zero to candidate exclusive
is 30. The difference is minus six. What remained
from candidate to the end is six what remains in
the pot before candidate is minus six by adding
them together we get zero which is positive. So
candidate is the valid station. Question. What if
we got a negative result here, then with Akutan
minus one because there is no valid stations.
But what if the valid station comes after
the candidate, it's impossible. Once again,
the station forma we started candidate
has an advantage over next stations,
we know that gas of candidate is greater than
or equal to cost of candidate. So even if with
that bonus, we get a negative remaining amount of
gas, it will also be the case for next stations.
Let's jump to the code on the side all of
this remaining starts at zero. And same
thing for candidate because at the beginning, we
assume that the first station is the candidate,
the potential valley station. Now we start
traversing stations. For each station, we update
remaining gas, we are guests of our answer truck
cost of AI. And if remaining becomes negative,
we sell that to start again from APL small, it
becomes a new candidate, and remaining becomes
zero because we will start again. After the loop,
we calculate the remaining gas of the pot before
candidate the sum of gas minus the sum of costs
of the pot from zero to candidate X clause IV.
Now we have three possible cases we have
the case or candidate is equal to and
it means that we reached the end of the
array without finding a potential station,
no station made it to the end
of the array, we return minus
one. So in case we have a candidate, but when
adding prev remaining, we found the negative
result, it means that it stopped somewhere
in the pot from zero to candidate return
minus one. And third case, we have a candidate and
remaining plus prayer remaining is not negative.
So candidate is the false station for more we
start to be able to do a full cycle, we return it.
In code. If candidates is equal to
length of gas, the number of stations,
or remaining prosperity remaining is smaller than
zero, we return minus one else we return candidate
who can even keep track of remaining in the first
loop to avoid traversing again to calculate the
sums. For the time complexity, we just have a loop
that does n iterations all other operations are in
over one, we get an off and on complexity, where n
is the number of stations much better than O of n
squared. Add a constant space complexity because
we're not using inputs all related variables.
Basically, in the solution, we search
for the candidate the station that made
it to the end of the array without
reaching a negative amount of gas.
Then we check if it still boosts up
when traversing remaining stations,
those in the pot from the beginning of the
array until going back to it who's the end
of this video. I hope that you understood the
optimal solution and see what the next one
Welcome back to the course in this lecture
rules of the course scheduled problem,
we have n courses labeled from zero to n
minus one in clauses that we need to take.
But some of them are prerequisites the other, we
cannot take a course before taking the other one.
And we have to determine if it's possible to
finish all the courses. So we are given an integer
as representing the number of courses and an
array prerequisites who are prerequisites of r is
equal to a b means that you first need to take the
course P before taking the course a. For example,
if we have this input, the output should be false.
Because to take course three, we must have taken
course zero, and to take her zero must have taken
course one. And to take course one, we must have
taken course three, it is impossible, it's
like we have a dependency cycle. This is
why we cannot finish all the courses return
false. But with this input, the output is true,
we can take or zero then course three, then
course one, then course five, then of course two,
that course for each course will have its
prerequisite satisfied when taking it.
How to solve this problem. Here we have
elements, courses and relationships between them,
of course being approved was that of a novel
course. And every time we faced this situation,
having elements and relationships between
them, you should think of using a graph.
I'm not saying that it will always give the best
solution. But even if it doesn't, it will at least
give you a way to visualize the problem with
vertices and links between them. In our case,
the vertices represent courses and edges
represent dependencies and add from u to
v means that we first need to take the course
you before being able to take the course fee.
Okay, now we build our graph, we got a
directed graph what we will do with it.
Our goal now is to search for dependency cycle.
If we find one, it means that it's impossible
to finish all the courses return false. Else if we
don't find one at all, it means that it's possible
to finish the mole return true. Basically, we're
searching for a cycle in a directed graph. In a
linked list, a classic way to check if there is a
cycle is to traverse a linked lists while saving
visited nodes. And if we step on a node that we
visited before, it means that there is a cycle.
We can think of applying the same logic for graph
which covers with depth first search, for example,
while using a set of visited notes. And if we step
on a node that has already been visited, it means
that we have a cycle return false. By the way, if
you don't know about the full search, it's a way
of traversing trees and graphs by diving deep into
a direction until we can move forward anymore.
Go back, try and all the way and so on. I made a
huge video about the subject that you can watch.
You need to know about DFS before continuing
this video is a prerequisite intended pun.
But this strategy doesn't always
work. Here is a counter example.
We have this graph let's start traversing. We
start for example from two we put it in visit it
we move to zero we pull it in visit it will
move to three we pretend visit. This one has
no outgoing others, we backtrack, this one has
no remaining neighbors to traverse we backtrack.
From here we move to the second neighbor one we
put it in visit it will move to four we put it
in visited. Then from here we move to three
and it's already in visited so our strategy
would return false. Which is wrong because
we can totally finish all the courses here.
We can start with two then zero then three than
one than four, all prerequisites are respected.
Was the solution done? Well, let me
first talk about topological sort.
We have a directed graph where vertices represent
tasks and an ad from u to v means that u is
a prerequisite of V. topological sort is the
process of finding a linear ordering of vertices
such that each vertex comes after is perquisites.
And all the words, for each edge from u to v,
V must come after you in the ordering. For
example, for this graph here is a valid ordering.
Know that a valid ordering is not always unique,
it's possible to find all the orderings that
satisfy the condition. But the logical sort is
not always possible. It's not possible when the
graph contains a cycle like this one. B is a
prerequisite of C, C is a prerequisite of D, D
is a prerequisite of E and E is a prerequisite of
B, so we have no way to order them. Fortunately,
while performing the topological sort, we can
detect the existence of a cycle. If it happens,
we just stop and say that we cannot have a valid
ordering of vertices. And it's exactly what we
want to do in our problem who have courses.
Some of them are prerequisites the other ones,
and we want to know if we can take all the courses
and all the terms if a valid ordering exists.
Therefore, who will use the biological source
and if during the process, we found the cycle
return false. Otherwise return true because it
means that we've been able to make an ordering.
Okay, but how does topological salt work? A
possible way to implement a biological source
is depth first search. Let's, for example, soft
foam this vertex, we put it on the past stack,
the pastor contains the vertices of the actual
path. B is its neighbor, we go to it, and we
put it on the past stack is his neighbor, we go
to it, and we put it on the path stack. He is
his neighbor, we go to it, and
we put it on the path stack.
Now it has no neighbors, it means that
we can safely put it in our ordering,
because there are no vertices that have to come
after it is perquisite of no one, we put it in the
order stack and we backtrack to the previous node.
Next neighbor is I will go to it and we put it on
the path stack. Same again, it has no neighbors,
who remove it from path stack and pull it
on all the stack. And we backtrack. Next neighbor
is if we go to it, J is a neighbor, we go to it,
it has no neighbors, we move it from path stack,
we put it on all their stack, and we backtrack.
Next neighbor is all but it's already visited. It
has no more unvisited neighbors, so all vertices
have to come after it in the ordering our visit,
we can safely put this one and we backtrack.
This one also has no more unvisited neighbors,
we can put it in order staff, and we backtrack.
And the process continues like that. Until
we traverse the whole graph of the end,
we get this ordering, we reverse it together from
the beginning to the end. Now the opposite. encode
our DFS function takes us parameters to graph
the vertex promo we start the path stock,
the oldest stack and the set of visited notes. We
start by adding our vertex to the past, just when
we start traversing it, then for each unvisited
neighbor, who first added to visit it, and we call
DFS with it as an argument to traverse it. After
doing so for all the neighbors who can safely put
the actual vertex on the oldest stack will pop
up from past stack and give it to all the stack.
And in our main top sort function, it takes us
an argument the adjacency list of our graph,
it squares the visit itself,
the Bastok, the older stack,
then it visits each unvisited vertex
with DFS. After doing so, the other
stack is filled with turns reverse together the
ordering from the first vertex to the last one.
Now the opposite. And starting from this
algorithm, we can add instructions to detect cycle
we find the cycle when you find a back arch,
and as that goes from vertex u to a vertex V,
where V is already in the path stack. Like here
we have a B, C, D, E, then he has B as a neighbor,
which is already on the path stack. This graph
contains a cycle B and E depends on each other.
In Code, our DFS function will not be a Boolean
function. It returns if yes or no we've been
able to make an ordering. What we add is that
before moving to a neighbor, we check if it's not
already in the stack. If it's the case, without
a return false, we can't make a valid ordering.
Also, if traversing enable returns false, it means
that we found a cycle one going from there. This
is why if the recursive code turns false, will
also return false here. And if we've been able
to traverse neighbors without getting a negative
result return true, we could make an ordering.
Know that to optimize checking for the
existence of the actual vertex in the stack,
it's better to use a set instead of a list
searching and assert is an old one time an average
pass doc now is of type set at the beginning we
add our vertex to it after the Lupu move it out to
add it to all the stack. And in our main solution
function, we first need to build the graph
because input will have the number of courses and
the list of prerequisites. Now the adjacency list
to build the adjacency list, we know
the number of vertices so we create
an array of N empty arrays. Each one
will contain neighbors of the course I
know which are first prerequisites of the problem
says that prerequisite of one has to come before
prerequisite of zero. So create an ad from
prerequisite of one two prerequisite of zero.
In other words, who add prerequisite of
02 neighbors have prerequisite of one.
Now that we've built the adjacency list, we can
start traversing but before we create the visit
itself, the past arc which is also a set on
the order stack, For each and visited course,
who added to visit, and if calling DFS with it
returns false, it means that we couldn't build
the old, we found the cycle. So return
false, who can't study all the courses
out of the loop doesn't return false, it means
that we could find an ordering because all
the order courses return true. And we've been able
to solve our problem. For the time complexity,
we're just performing dub for search on a graph.
And the time complexity of DFS is often for v plus
length of E, will length of v is the number of
vertices and length of E, the number of edges,
ie the number of vertices is the number
of courses and, and the number of edges
is M for length of prerequisites list, who
got an off campus and found complexity.
And for the space complexity, we have the space
for the adjacency list length of v plus length
of E, the space for the visited set length of v,
the space for the path stack, and the older stack
length of v and the space for the call stack
length of v in total, who got full times length
of v plus length of v, which is an awful length
of v plus length of v, who does have apples.
Know that you may find a similar solution. But
with collars each vertex can have the color white,
gray or black. Compared to our solution,
what means and visited. Green means visited
and in the past dark, and black means
visited add not in the past anymore,
we've put it in the order. And if
we found the neighbor that is great,
it means that it's in the actual path, and we
found it again. So we have a cycle return false.
No implemented topological sort with depth
first search. But we can also implement it
with breadth first search. Let me show you how.
If you don't know about breadth first search,
I made a YouTube video about it, I recommend
you to watch it before continuing this one.
The general idea of our second solution
is to split our directed graph into levels
and the first level, we have vertices that have no
prerequisites, we'll conduct this thought studying
them. Once we finish, we can remove them from
the graph by removing them from the graph. So
vertices won't have prerequisites anymore, because
their prerequisites were courses we just started
and they're satisfied. And these vertices
represent the second level, we'll put them in
our ordering and remove them after removing them,
so vertices won't have prerequisites anymore,
they represent the third level, we put
them in our ordering and remove them.
And the process continues like that
until we have no more vertices.
Both removing vertices from graph costs on time,
because we need to update the adjacency list.
Instead, we'll keep track of
the integral of each vertex
and when we traverse a vertex, we decrement
the integral of all these neighbors,
the in degree of a vertex is the number of edges
that are entering it. For example, the integral
of this vertex is to so when we remove a vertex
that is going to it would decremented in degree
and if the integral of a vertex becomes zero,
it feels at all its perquisites are satisfied,
who can traverse it, we put it in the queue. With
his graph, we call the integral of each vertex,
we search for vertices with an integral
of zero, we put them in the queue and you
apply classic BFS traversal. The difference
is that when we pop a node from the queue,
who start by putting it in the ordering array
because it has no remaining prerequisites,
also want to traverse a neighbor with
decremented in degree, and if it becomes zero,
we put it in the queue. Last thing would
not need a visited set, because we're not
putting a vertex in the queue until we finish
traversing all vertices that are going to it.
So we don't have the risk of traversing a vertex
again. With this graph, this is what happens.
Encode will create an array of an
empty arrays as we did with DFS,
but we'll also add an array of N zeroes
to solve the integral of each vertex.
Now when filling the adjacency list will also
increment in degree of prerequisite of zero
because prerequisite of zero is the vertex
where the edge enters, so incremented in degree
now we'll create an array where
we'll put our ordering and a queue.
The queue initially contains
vertices hoes in degrees zero,
after it will start traversing while the cool
still contains elements will pop a vertex we
add it to ordering because it has no unsatisfied
prerequisites, and we traverse its neighbors for
each With different methods in degree, and if it
becomes zero, we incue it as explained earlier.
After the loop, the other array is not filled, we
return it. This time, we don't need to reverse it
because we started by putting vertices of level
zero than one and so on. With this topological
sort algorithm, we can also detect cycles.
When the graph contains cycles. What happens
is that at some point of the process, we will
have no more vertices with an index of zero,
which means that nothing will be inserted in the
queue, the process stops earlier, the array will
contain less than the total number of vertices,
who will deduce that the process couldn't continue
because there is a cycle. And in our problem, who
just want to know if we can make an ordering or
not, this is why after the loop, who will just
compare the length of the order array with add
the number of courses either equal, the
algorithm returns true, else it returns false.
So we keep the same code who just changed
the return statement with a length of order
equal to add. For the time complexity,
we're just applying breadth first search,
which has an off length of the plus length of
a time complexity O of n plus m in our problem.
And for the space complexity, we have length
of v plus length of a for the adjacency list,
length of v for the in degree array, and
length of v for the queue of the ordered array,
three times length of v plus length of
V gives offline for v plus length of E,
which is of m plus m and our problem,
we get an off campus M space complexity.
We reached the end of this video in this
one, we solve the CO schedule problem
with two different ways. I hope that you
understood them both and seen the next one.
Welcome back to the course in this lecture, we
will solve the Kieth permutation problem with
a range of numbers from one to n in clause
IV, who can make n factorial permutations.
by labeling them in order starting from one,
you're asked to return the Keith permutation.
For example, with n equal to three and
k equal to three, here are the three
factorial permutations of 123 labeled animateur K
is three, so we turn the third one to one, three.
The first solution that may come in your
mind is obviously the brute force solution,
generating all the permutations doesn't return
the case one, we give to the function the range
from one to n in closet, then we return the one at
index k minus one. Remember that an array is zero
indexed, so the Keith one is at index k minus one.
But the problem with this solution is that with
n elements, we can make n factorial permutations
of lung add that it costs n times n factorial to
generate them, we get n or m times n factorial
time complexity Soulshine, which is extremely
slow. We did use the tree to solve this problem
is to be able to find the permutation without
generating the permutations. And this is what
we'll see now. Let's take n equal to four. Now
take a paper or notepad software, list all the
permutations of 1234 in order and tell me what
do we notice, I want you to take some minutes
to analyze the structure of those permutations.
Here are all the permutations we have a
total of four factorial permutations 24.
Who can notice that these 24 permutations can be
divided into four parts. The first one contains
permutations that start with one, the second
one contains permutations that starts with two,
and so on. Let's suppose that we want to
find a 16th permutation k equal to 16.
If we label them starting from zero, it means
that we want to find the permutation 15.
Because 16 is one we label them starting from
one. The question now is, can we find what part
among these four parts of permutation 15 will
be? The answer is yes, by using math. We know
that the first part contains permutations from
zero to five in clause, the second one from six
to 11 in closet, the third one from 12 to 17, in
closet, and the last one from 18 to 23. In Closet.
To find which one we'll just divide K by the
length of a part, which is six in our case.
15 divided by six gives two so the permutation 15
won't be in the pot zero won't be in the pot one,
but it will be in the part two. Now that
we're working with zero index labeling,
we know that the part two contains permutations
that starts with three. So we already know that
our Keith permutation will start with a three
and it will be one of these permutations.
Let's continue. What's gonna happen now
is that the search space will be reduced.
Now we know that our case permutation
will be in these six permutations.
We need to update variables. K needs to be more
Initially we were searching for permutation
15 Among all the permutations, but in this
group of six permutations, we're searching
for permutation three, why three, because 15
and model six, the length of the pod is three.
Case 15, when we start from permutation zero,
but in this particular part it will label
permutation starting from zero, whose solution for
permutation three, and also represents the number
of remaining elements of the permutation to find
and found one, so we decrement and becomes three
and factorial also changes it becomes three
factorial six. Same thing for pot length,
it also gets updated six divided by three is two.
We also remove three from a news elements because
we already found its place in the permutation,
and our permutation doesn't contain duplicates.
Who can divide these six permutations into
three parts of two elements, the first part
contains permutations holds the second element
is one, the second part contains permutations
hosts the second element is to other third parts
contains permutations who is the third element is
41214. All the elements or two we
didn't use it in our permutation.
Case three now can we find the pot case
permutation belongs to yes once again we divide
by the pot length, three divided by two gives
one so the case permutation will be in part one.
And we know that permutations of
Part One have to our second element,
so the second element of our permutation will
be to, again the search space will be reduced we
know that our kid permutation will be in these
two permutations. This is why we update the
variables k gets modified as we did previously,
it becomes k models the length of part three
models two gives one it means that among these two
permutations, we're switching for permutation one,
and gets decremented it becomes two which changes
the value of n factorial two factorial is two.
Which also changes the value part length,
and factorial divided by n is two divided
by two which is one. We can divide these two
permutations into two parts of one permutation,
the first part contains permutations
holds the third element is one,
and the second part contains permutations
holds the third element is for,
to know the path or case permutation belongs to,
who divided by the port land, the path length here
is one and one divided by one gives one, our
permutation will be in part one. permutations
of part one how for as a third element, so the
third element of our permutation will be four.
We do use the search space we know that
our permutation will be in this part of
one permutation, we update variables, k becomes k
models the port length, one model is one zero, and
becomes one and factorial becomes one pot length
becomes one and we move for from a news elements.
We divide this one permutation
into one part of one permutation.
The first part will contain permutations host,
one is the fourth element, the length of a part
is one, and k divided by one gives zero. So our K
permutation will be in pod zero. And permutations
of pod zero have one is fourth element. So the
fourth element of our permutation will be one
now and becomes zero and it gets
decremented. So we'll finish the process.
The case permutation is 3241, who found it
without generating all the permutations.
If you didn't understand what we've been doing
here, let me show it to you in another way.
You first need to understand
how our permutations generated
are the beginning who have no
choices forming this example.
And because we want all the permutations, we try
all possibilities. When we add one when we add
212 and three, add one, add four, this is why
you're seeing four branches are the beginning.
And we're talking about permutations without
repetitions. So when we take an element,
we remove it from possible choices. This is why
when we take two other beginning for example,
lat branch creates three branches only not
411111, a three and one one, we add four,
you can see that we didn't add two
again. And when we take four for example,
we have two choices left one or
three, we get two new branches only.
Then when we take one of them, we have
one choice left, the one we didn't take
part in our problem we want to find the case one.
The way we solve this problem is by using math
to calculate what branch we should go from
to reach the combination we searching for.
Imagine that you have 1000 books labeled from
zero to 999. Let's say that you're searching
for the book 436 You remember that these books
are organized into Turn boxes have 100 elements.
The first one contains books from zero
to 99, the second one from 100, to 199,
and so on how to know which book to search, and
you simply divide the number of the book you're
searching for by the size of a box, because here
they have the same size. 436 divided by 100 is
four, we searched in box four, we still didn't
find the book, but we reduce the search space.
Now, we will search for book 36 In this box of
100. Why, because 436 modules 100, the pot length
gives the receipts. Once again, the 100 books
of the books four are organized in 10 boxes of
10 books each, the first one contains books from
zero to nine after for hundreds, the second one
from 10 to 19, after for hundreds, and so on.
The book size is 1036 divided by 10 gives three,
we search in box three. In that box three, we
search for book six because 36 modulus 10 is six,
so on and so on until we found the
book without traversing all the books.
And basically this is what
we did to solve this problem.
Let's try to generalize or the beginning we'll
have n k add in us that contains elements in the
range from one to adding clause if now while n is
greater than zero, who stopped by calculating the
port length, it's an factorial divided by n.
After it, we calculate the index of the next
element to put in the permutation. Remember that
we calculated by dividing cable the port length,
after we calculated we add an use of either
the permutation either deleted from unused
who add an use of oil because it represents the
common element in the if part. Then we decrement
n and k becomes K model a spot length to get
its new position in the path that we choose.
who keep repeating that and when a becomes
zero, we have our case permutation and we
solve the problem. In code, we have a function
that takes as parameters and key the given input
or create an empty array for the permutation
we're searching for. Then you create and used,
it contains elements of the run want to
add in clause if afterward to avoid all is
recalculating our factorial recruiting the very
fact we're factoring it represents a factorial,
it contains n plus one elements to have the
values from zero factorial to n factorial.
To fill it, we know that zero factorial is one.
And for remaining elements, we just take the value
of the previous cell and we multiply it by I, for
example, with five who got 1126 24 120. Now we
decrement k, because k represents the position
of the permutation with one index labeling,
but we're working with zero index labeling, okay
becomes k minus one to fit. We're working with
zero index labeling. To simplify the math, we get
the right result when we divide and use modules.
Who can start the loop now, while n is greater
than zero, Portland is an factorial factor of
n divided by an avant the index of the
element to take is k divided by potluck.
After getting the index of
the next element, which is I
who are unused of our to our permutation, and
we delete the element at index i from N used
before moving to the next permutation with
decrement N, and k becomes k models pot length.
After the loop, our permutation is built, we just
join its elements into a string and return it
will return the case permutation
as required by the problem.
Basically, the solution will may now use this
math to keep calculating the part of the case
permutation belongs to, because by knowing it, we
know what is the next element to take from unused
and use, which is the array of elements we
didn't use yet. For the time complexity,
creating a news cost and creating factory
costs are plus one and film get costs. And
then the while loop gets repeated while and
is greater than zero. And Angus recommended
that each iteration, so the number of iterations
is equal to the initial value of an inside it,
all operations are in all one, except popping the
element I found and used can have the case where
we need to shift all the elements to the left
and entered all the elements of the permutation
were four n plus n squared plus one who got an O
of n squared time complexity, way better than O of
n times n factorial of the first solution. And
for the space complexity, we have n for a news
and permutation and n plus one for fact array, two
m plus one gives us an O of n space complexity.
Where is the end of this video? I hope that
you at least understood the general idea of
the second solution, which is dividing the
perimeter Asians into pause with a common
element and calculating which part of the key
permutation belongs to see you the next lecture
Welcome back to the course in this lecture, we
will solve the minimum window substring problem,
we have two strings SN T, and we're asked to
find the shortest substring of us that contains
all characters of T. If such a substring
doesn't exist, return the empty string.
For example, if we have this input as output, we
get C E A, B, E, ba, is the shortest substring
of our salt contains all characters of t, in all
the words, two A's, one B and one C. First of all,
how can we know that a string contains all
characters of another one who can't know it by
having the counter frequencies of each string,
the one we use in the valid anagram problem,
if record is the counter of as one and for to the
counter of as two, for every distinct character of
as two for one of CH must be greater than or equal
to for two of CH in other words, as one must have
at least the number of occurrences of CH and
s to encode will write for each CH in for two.
If rec one of CH is smaller than freq, two of
CH will return false after the loop return true.
Knowing this, we cannot really think of a
solution, the brute force solution, which covers
all possible substrings of us while keeping track
of the shortest wall that has all characters of t.
In Code, who can add an early exit condition. If
t is longer than us, we can't find the substring
that satisfies the condition, there isn't enough
characters without glue join the empty string.
Same result when t is empty,
who can return the empty string,
because technically, the empty string contains
all the characters of the empty string.
Else who first create a counter for T to
know the frequency of each character in it,
let's name it for t. We also need the string
shortest that represents the shortest valid
substring that we found until now, it initially
has amples one characters to be sure that it gets
updated as soon as we found the valid sub train.
Now we start traversing substrings of us to do so
we start by traversing the length, because we will
start by traversing substrings of one character
than substrings of two characters and so on.
This is why learn goes from one to adding clauses
inside it, whichever starting positions, because
with the same length, we have the substring the
source at index zero, the water source at index
one, and so on. But it doesn't go until the end
to avoid going out of bounds when adding the
length I goes from zero to n minus length in
clause if we have the starting position, which is
I will have the length of the actual substring.
So we can extract the actual substring is the one
between I in clause 11 i plus length fix clauses.
Now that we got the substring, we'll create a
counter for it. Let's name it for us, after it
will give the actual substring replaces
the shortest one who found until now,
for that two conditions, the actual
substring must contain all characters of t,
we can't know it when the function we made and
it must be shorter than the actual shortest one.
The length of the actual substring is length.
So if length is smaller than length of shortest
will replace shortest becomes the substring.
After the loop who don't don't quote on shortest,
because it's possible that we didn't find any
substring that contains all characters of T
to know that we took the length of
shortest. If it's still n plus one,
it means that it doesn't get updated, we return
the empty string as required by the problem,
else return shortest. Basically, we return
shortest one is length is at most n.
For the time complexity, let's say that
n and m all lengths of Sn T respectively,
will have N for building for T and n plus one for
creating shortest. Then we have n iterations for
the outer loop animal's life plus one iterations
for the inner loop. And inside it the cost of
extracting the substring. And generating the
counter depends on length. We also have the
cost of checking if it contains all characters,
which is because in the function which covers
characters of reg T, their number is at most m we
get this sum which is equal to one divided by six
times n times m plus one times three M plus two
and plus four was simplify. And in the worst case,
T is shorter than s. So M is smaller than
n. We're going off and coupon complexity.
And for the space complexity, we have amphiphilic
T amples, one for shortest and for sub n n for
fracas we'll get three and Paul samples one,
which gives them off samples and space complexity.
This solution is obviously very slow is
not the best one. This is why we will move
to the second solution. Inside the inner
loop, we have a cost of length to extract
a cost of length who generate the counter and cost
of arm to check if it contains all characters?
What if we try to reduce this cost to over one?
To get a constant cost per in a loop iteration?
Follow me well, how can we extract
the substring and old one? In reality,
we will need to extract the substring and our
second solution, who will just work with the start
and end indexes of the substring? Which are i and
i plus length, we already know them. Second thing,
how can we generate the counter of the actual
substring and oh one, the trick is to not always
build the counter again, who will use the one
of the previous substring. Let me show you how.
Emergent that we have this
string, US ABC a D CB AC.
And the first sell triangle five characters has
this counter two A's, one B, one C and one T.
Starting from this counter, how can we get the
counter of the next substring of five characters,
which is this one? To do. So we'll just increment
the number of occurrences of the character that
went out of the window and increment the number
of occurrences of the character that went in
the window. The one that went out is a it was
in the first substring, but not in the second
with decrement fracks of A, it becomes more
than the one that went in is he it's in the
second substring, but not in the first one
who increment for x of e, it becomes one.
And we got the new countering old one because
no matter the length of the substring,
we need to work on two characters, only the
one that went out and the one that went in,
there will always be only two because
we're moving by one position at a time.
Then for the next substring. Same logic, the one
that went out is B so with the command for X of B
and the one that went NTC. So increment for x
of C. And the process continues like that for
all sub strings of length five. The technique
we're using here is called sliding window.
In our example, we were using a window of length
five. Then to move to the next substring we don't
start again from the beginning, we just move the
window by performing the necessary changes. And we
just focus on what went out of the window and what
entered not what's inside because it won't change.
Last thing to optimize the cost of
checking if it contains all characters,
the cost is actually M because we need to
traverse characters of rec T Mobile let me
show you how to optimize it. In our example, T is
ABC a it has three distinct characters A, B and
C. So we have three conditions to respect to say
that our substring contains all characters of t,
the conditions are at least two occurrences
of a at least one occurrence of b, at least
one occurrence of C. The idea to avoid always
traversing all the characters, which can cause
um, is to keep track of how many conditions
are satisfied. And for the actual substring,
the number of satisfied conditions is equal to the
length of reg T, which has a number of distinct
characters of t, then the actual substring
contains all characters of T It's a valid one.
Okay, but some characters are going out of
the window and some of them are accurate,
which means that when moving the window, some
satisfied conditions can become unsatisfied,
and vice versa. Some unsatisfied conditions
can become satisfied how to handle that.
To do so, after incrementing the number of
occurrences of the counter that went in,
if it's in fact T and frakkers of want
n becomes equal to FRAC to point n,
it means that we didn't have enough occurrences
of the characters that went in. And now we do
so a new condition is satisfied,
who increments satisfied.
And before decrementing, the number of
occurrences of the character that went out
if it's in fact T and for us of one out is equal
to for active one out, it means that we had enough
occurrences of the characters that went out, but
after decrementing, we won't because for us of one
out will be smaller than what's required. This
is why we Diekmann satisfied, a condition that
was satisfied before is not satisfied anymore.
And we decrement for x of one out obviously.
For example here we have these strings SN t
and we have this window of seven characters,
the conditions are at least two occurrences
of a at least one occurrence of p
at least one occurrence of C. Here we have one
occurrence of a two occurrences of B and one
occurrence of C. Only two conditions are satisfied
not enough. Let's move the window. Now he wants
out but we don't care because it's not a character
of t with the command for X but nothing happens.
And a went in who increment for X of A
and it becomes equal to fracture of A,
we satisfied a new condition, the number
of conditions is equal to length of rec t.
So the substring is valid, it contains all
characters of reg T, all conditions are satisfied.
We move the window, now see what's out of the
window, and is number of occurrences in the
substring is equal to the number of occurrences
in t. So, when we decrement because it's one out,
the condition becomes unsatisfied.
We don't have enough C's anymore.
And the answer is the window. But we
don't care. It's not a character of t.
Now the number of satisfied conditions is smaller
than what's required. This substring doesn't
contain all characters of t. And the process
continues like that. Once again, no matter
the length of the window, we're dealing with two
characters, only the one that went in and the one
that went out. So checking if the actual substring
is valid because of one we've been able to
optimize extracting the substring, generating the
counter and checking if the substring is valid.
We've seen how to do all these in old one. But he
didn't see the code yet. Let's move to the code.
We keep the same old exit condition, we
generate the counter of t. But now we don't
save the shortest string itself. We just save it
started and position. Initially shortest sources
a string of samples one characters, so initialize
thought and and zero and amples one respectively.
Now we start traversing lengths. What we were
doing in the example is to update frogs according
to characters that went in and out compared to
the previous position of the window. But to do so,
we first did an initial window that's
also zero and hose the length is length
arrow, traverse it normally to fill frogs
and count the number of satisfied conditions.
We create fracks and recreate satisfied a
variable to keep track of the number of satisfied
conditions. It initially starts at zero because
we didn't start traversing characters of as yet,
we didn't satisfy any condition. Then we
traverse characters of the first window,
for each character ch will increment flux of
ch. And if CH is a character of T and flux
of CH becomes equal to react, you have ch now
the number of occurrences of CH became enough,
a new condition is satisfied, who increments
satisfied. After processing the first window,
we check if it's a valid substring before moving
to all the ones and if it should replace the
actual shortest one. If satisfied is equal to
length of reg t, the number of conditions and
length is smaller than the length of the actual
shortest substring, which is add minus thought
replace, start an N becomes zero and length
respectively, the boundaries of the first window.
Now we can start traversing all the
sub strings are the same length,
I start at one and zero
because the first sub string,
which is the first window is already
processed, we start from the second one.
We want to work with the character that went out
of the window and the one that went in bought,
where are them. The actual substring is between
indexes I in clauses when I post length exclusive,
the character that went out comes just before
the window. So its index is i minus one.
And the one that went in is the last character of
the window, its index is i plus length minus one,
we can start working, the character that entered
the window is opposition ai plus length minus one.
So increment for x of s of Ai plus length minus
one. Now if it's a character of T and its number
of occurrences and the substring became equal to
the number in t, it means that the new condition
is satisfied, we write if as of apples length
minus one in fact T and flux of hours of eyeballs
length minus one is equal to freq T of s of i
plus length minus one, we increment satisfied.
After it, we work with a character that went out
the one at index i minus one if it's a cocktail of
T and S number of occurrences and the substring
is equal to its number of occurrences in t
it means that a condition was satisfied but not
anymore, because we will decrement for x of s
of n minus one. So it will become smaller than
freq T of s of i minus one not enough occurrences
of x of i minus one anymore. We write if as of i
minus one in fact T and for x of s of i minus one
equal to T of s of i minus one with the
cumin satisfied will also satisfied condition
after it with the CaroMont
for x of s of i minus one.
Now that we know the number of satisfied
conditions by the actual substring the one between
i and i plus Lang who can check if it replaces the
actual shortest one, we write If satisfied equal
to the length of reg T and length is smaller
than n minus thought, we replace thought and
by i and i plus length respectively, we found a
shorter string that contains all characters of T.
After the loop, soften and represent the
boundaries of the shortest substring,
but only found one. If underline his thought
is greater than n, then we didn't update
start and end, we turned the empty string
because we didn't find any valid substring.
Else, we told the part of us between starting
clause event and X closet. What about the time
complexity, we'll have time for building for T
n iterations for the outer loop. Then inside it,
we have linked iterations for the first loop,
and one is length iterations for the second bond,
and all operations inside the mind of
one plus n for returning the part of us
length plus and minus length gives n and we
can ignore M, we've got an O of n squared
time complexity, the space complexity doesn't
change. You can see that now we've been able to
reduce the time complexity from F and Q to off
n squared isn't enough. No, we can do better.
When using sliding window, we have the case where
the window size is fixed. For example, if we have
an array of integers and are asked to find the
key consecutive elements with the greatest sum,
we use a window of size k, we will move
it but we won't change its size because
we know that the array we're searching for
is of length k. However, in our problem,
we don't know the size of the shortest
substring that contains all characters.
This is why we tried all possible lengths,
which are sub strings of length one
than those of them do, and so on, which
resulted in an O of n squared time complexity.
But we have another way of manipulating the
window, instead of sliding the window by
one position. In other words extended from the
right by one and reduce it from the left by one,
what we can do is to extend it from the right by
one, but reduce it from the left by a number of
times that is between zero and the length of
the window. Depending on what we want to do.
Let's apply to our problem.
Theory of the strategy that we're going to use
is to find the shortest substring that answer the
actual index of write that respects the condition,
which is containing all characters of tea.
Obviously keeping track of shortest one among
the more the one that will be returned our via
let's start for the first index, we find an A
but no condition is satisfied, we need to as
next index, we find d, we don't care about it.
Next index we find c a condition is satisfied.
Next index if we don't care. Next
index e we don't care. Next index B,
the second condition is satisfied, but not all
of them. Next index e we don't care. Next index
see we have two Cs now, better condition is still
missing. Next index, he won't care. Next index
a, we now have two A's, which is
enough to satisfy the last condition.
All conditions are satisfied now, it means that
the substring from left to right in clause is
valid. But is it the shortest one that answer
the index, right? Not true. Because we may
have characters that we don't care about by
characters that we don't care about, I mean
characters that we can remove without breaking
the validity of the actual string. And these
characters are characters that are not in TRL and
calculus of t that are in excess in our substring.
For example, if we need to see is only and we have
five C's in our substring who can remove the first
three wants to make the substring shorter while
satisfying the condition. Remember that our goal
is to get the shortest valid substring. Who cannot
remove from the metal because characters of a
substring must be ages. And we cannot remove from
the right because we're searching for the shortest
valid substring that answer the actual position
of right. So we can only remove from the left
will keep removing while the characters position
left is a character we don't care about.
Here the character off left is a
it's in T and it's not an excess.
We need two A's and we have exactly two. So
this one is important. We cannot remove it.
We finish removing from the left. So the
shortest substring that answer right is this one
is length is smaller than the actual shortest
one, we update. We move to the next position of
Freud who find the be the one at left is still
important. So the shortest one is this one.
But we don't update because it's not the global
shortest one. Next position, we find an E the
counter left is still important. Next position we
find to be the character left is still important.
Next addition, we found in a and here is where
things change, because the character at left
is not important anymore. The reason behind it
is that we found another A, which means that
the character is now in excess, we can remove
the first one without breaking the Validate
he will move a and with the
command is number of occurrences.
Let's see if we can continue removing D is not
an important character is not in T, we move it
C is in T but we have more than enough
we have two C's while we need only one
we move and decrement is number of occurrences
of is not empty. Remove is not empty, remove it.
These in excess we remove it is not empty, we
remove it. C is in T and it's not in excess.
So we stopped removing. We found out that the
shortest valid substring that antithyroid is c
e a b e BA and it's like the seven smaller than
the length of the actual shortest one replace.
Let's continue. We'll move to the next position of
right. By the way, if you're wondering why aren't
we going back to the beginning going to increment
right is because we know that characters before
the actual position of love aren't important.
We don't need the for the actual substring.
Who found the D the cow top left is
still important and we don't update
because the length is not smaller than seven.
Next position who find half the characters
left is still important and we don't update.
Next position we find the seat which means that
the character at left is not important anymore.
The character sees in excess we can remove it is
not in T we also remove it is important because
it's in T and it's not in excess we stopped
removing we get a B e b a DFC, which is not
shorter than the actual shortest. We don't update
we continue with on D and A still important.
Next position we find f is still important.
Next position, we find c an ACL important.
Basically it will continue like this for the next
five positions. And there is no update because the
substring is getting longer. We're not being able
to remove from the left and in the next position
we find an eight so the one on the left is not
important anymore, we remove it. These in excess
we remove it is not empty, we move it be still in
Excel. So remove it is not in Excel. So we stop
the substring is a DFC, DFC BFC BA, but not short
enough to update. last index, we find d and a
still important, we don't update and we finish
traversing as the global shortest substring that
contains all characters of t is the one between
indexes seven and 13 and clauses, it c a b e BA,
take some seconds to process what you've
seen until now before continuing the video.
Let's move to the code. We keep the same URL
the exit condition we build for it as we did
previously, we initialize thought and add on
zero and respectively. We initialize satisfied
zero regret for x which is empty at the beginning.
And we add a variable left that represent the left
boundary of the window here and started on and not
n plus one because now Andrew presents the last
nfo the window is in closet. Also, you can see
that we created frogs and satisfied outside the
loop because we won't traverse lengths as we did
in the previous solution. We don't need to do that
will darkly traverse positions of right the right
boundary of the window for each position right
we increment the number of occurrences of the
character obviously, an objective is satisfied a
condition as we did in the previous solution if
as of right is in fact T and flux of arthritis
equal to for active as a Freud who satisfy the
condition so increments satisfied. Basically the
path before satisfying all the conditions. This
is what we need to do only incrementing the number
of occurrences and checking if we satisfied a
condition remember that we're expanding from
the right only less remains zero. But once we
satisfy all the conditions which we can verify
with this condition, satisfied equal to length
of FRAC t we can start removing from the left.
We don't know how many characters are we going
to remove from the window. So we use a while
loop. We saw that we keep removing characters
while the character has left is an important
and a character that is not important. means
that either is not a character of the origin
access means we have more than what's required. We
write while as of last noted for akti or flux of
us have left greater than for active as of left.
Inside the loop, we move the car out which means
that we decrement its number of occurrences
in frogs and move left to the next position.
Now that we removed all unnecessary characters
who go the shortest valid substring? That answer
the actual position of right is the
one between left and rotting clause if
what do we do now, we check if it
replaces the actual global shortest one.
The length of the substring, we found now is
right minus left plus one plus one because
this time the right boundary, which is right
is included in the window. And the length
of the actual global shortest one is and minus
thought plus one plus one for the same reason.
So if right minus left plus one is smaller
than and minus that plus one, we update,
start and end become left and respectively.
After the loop, almost same return statement,
we just add plus one because and is included in
the window. Now, if we could update at least once
we turned the part of ASP video installed and
adding clause if else return the empty string.
By the way, you can see all of this time, we
weren't checking if we lost a satisfied condition.
Because we stopped removing as soon as we reached
the minimum required occurrences will never
go below it. This is why when the counter had
left was important. We weren't removing at all,
not like in the previous solution when we were
removing no matter what. For the time complexity,
we have an for building for T and
the outer loop does n iterations
is true that we have an inner while loop where
the tricky part is that its number of iterations
doesn't exceed n in total. I repeat in total.
Why? Simply because at each iteration of the
while loop, we're removing a character and we
have n characters. remaining operations are
owned over one. So the cost of the outer loop
isn't over. And yes, oh if and only not more,
who else pause and for extracting the output.
And in total, we have ample of ampersand,
we'll give some of ample time
complexity better than O of n squared.
And for the space complexity, same as the previous
solution of m plus m. And we've been able to solve
the problem in off campus m time only by
using a bunch of interesting optimizations.
One was a tough problem, I hope that you
understood how we built our optimal solution
that you will be able to use it to solve all the
problems. We've reached the end of this video,
it was a long one. But I tried to detail
each operation to let you understand what is
each line of code doing and how the algorithm
works in general. See you in the next video.
Welcome back to the course in this lecture, we
will solve the largest rectangle in histogram
problem. We are given an array heights that
contains the height of each bar in the histogram.
And we're asked to return the area of
the largest rectangle in the histogram.
Know that each bar has a width of one. For
example, if we have this input here is the
largest rectangle. It's area seven times five,
which gives 35. How can we solve this problem?
Let's for example, take this bar, it has a
height of two. Now, can you tell me what's
the largest rectangle of high two that passes
from this bar? Is this one. But how did we know?
Let's start from that bar and keep expanding? Can
we expand to the left? Yes, three is greater? Can
we expand? No, because we have no more bar from
the left? From the right now can we expand? Yes,
four is greater? Can we expand? Yes, five is
greater than two. In other words, this bar is
higher so our rectangle can pass from it. Can we
expand? Yes, seven is greed. Can we expand? Yes,
six is greed. Can we expand? No, we can't expand
from here because one is smaller than two. So if
we expand, the rectangle won't be fully included
in the histogram is not a valid rectangle.
We expanded as much as possible from both sides,
we go the largest rectangle that passes the
initial bar is this one, it has an area of 12 Two
times six, the height multiplied by the width.
And we can apply this strategy on each bar
while keeping track of the greatest area
of the end who will have found the greatest
area, because the largest rectangle necessarily
passes from a bar that has the same height as
itself. The reason behind it is that if the
rectangle is shorter than all the bars it passes
from, it means that it's not the largest one,
you can still make it bigger by increasing its
height. And if it's taller than at least one bar
learn is not fully included in the histogram.
It's not a valid rectangle. With this example,
with the first bar we get this rectangle with
the second bar we get this rectangle and so on.
The end The greatest area that we
find is 35. The area of this rectangle
encode we initialize Max area to zero because
we didn't traverse any rectangle. Therefore,
each bar I expand from both sides from each side,
we keep expanding while the bar is still higher or
as high as our bar. So we stopped when we found
the shorter one, or when we have no more bars.
Left thoughts are the actual position, then
while the previous bar exists and is at least
as high as the actual bar, we expand, we
move left by one position to the left.
Same logic with the right side but
by incrementing, right starts on I,
then while the next part exists, and is at
least as high as the actual bar, we expand,
we move right by one position to the right. While
right plus one smaller than N and height of right
plus one greater than or equal to height of
AI, we increment y to take it to the right.
Now that we know boundaries of our
rectangle, we need to calculate its area.
The area of a rectangle is the height multiplied
by the width, the height here is the height of
the initial bar height of i, and for the width is
the difference between left and right plus one,
right minus left plus one plus one because both
left and right are included in the rectangle.
Now we check if replace Max area becomes
the most between its actual value and the
area of the actual rectangle heights of our
multiplied by right minus left postponed.
After the loop, we just return max area.
For the time complexity, we're traversing the N
bars, and for each bar when searching for left
and right boundaries, who may traverse the whole
histogram. This is why we get an O of n squared
time complexity. In the worst case, the worst
case happens when all bars have the same height.
And for the space complexity, it's
constant, we're just using eight variables.
This solution is slow. Let's move to the next one.
There are interesting properties to know about the
shortest bar. The first one is that by starting
to make a rectangle from it, we can expand it
until the boundaries of the histogram because
there are no shorter ball to stop the expansion.
Second one, the rectangle starting from
any other ball can't pass through it,
except if it has the same height, but
we get the same rectangle in that case.
So the shortest part is like a wall, any other
rectangle will either be on his left side or on
his right side. From these two information, we
can make a solution based on divide and conquer.
We search for the shortest bar, and we have a
rectangle that traverses the whole histogram
will also recursively search for the
largest rectangle in the left side,
the largest rectangle in the right side, and
we take the maximum among these rectangles,
it represents the largest rectangle in the
whole histogram. The reason behind it is
that because our bar is the shortest one, we
can't have a taller rectangle that joins the
left on the right side, a taller rectangle will
either be in the left part or in the right part.
So we don't worry about missing the larger
rectangle, we can search in each side separately.
We also consider the rectangle host the height
is the height of the shortest bar, the one
that traverses the whole histogram, because
it's possible for it to be the largest one,
even if it has the smallest height, but its
width can make it the most interesting rectangle.
Encode recruiter recursive function that
takes us parameters the array of heights,
but also low and high the boundaries of the part
of the histogram we're searching in right now. Or
the beginning we search the whole histogram. So
low and high will be initialized to the index of
the first and the last bar. The first base case is
where the actual part is empty. While low exceeds
right, we just return zero, we have no rectangle.
Second base case one, we have only one bar,
one low is equal to high. In those case,
we just returned the height of that bar.
Else, we have the recursive case, we'll start by
calculating the position of the shortest bar in
the actual part. For that, we calculated
the smallest height in the actual part
between low and high in clause IV, then we
search for its index in the outro part again.
Now that we have it, we recursively search for
the greatest area and the left and right sides.
For the left part, we put postman minus one
as the right boundary. And for the right part,
we put postman postman as the left boundary.
URL for the short put wide rectangle, its height
is the minimum height we calculated before and
its width is the whole path we're searching in
high minus low plus one. So we turn the maximum
between from left form right and mean eight times
high minus low plus one. This one represents
the area of the short but while rectangle
we also need a long question function to call
this one, the initial values of low and high
are zero and n minus one, the index of
the first and last bar respectively.
For the time complexity, in the best case,
the shortest bar is always in the middle.
So in recursive cases, we divide the input size by
two, we have infosearch. And for the men, and two
times t of n by two for cursive calls, we get t of
n is equal to two times t of n divided by two plus
n. By using the master method, this recurrence
relation gives off n log n time complexity.
But in the worst case, the shortest bar is always
the first or the last bar. For example, when
it's the first one, from the love, the input size
becomes zero, we get to zero. But from the right,
the input size becomes n minus one, we get to
have animals one plus n to search for the minimum,
we got t of n is equal to t of n minus one plus n.
And if we keep replacing, this recurrence relation
gives off n squared time complexity, same as
the previous solution is like we didn't often
what's slowing down the process is finding the
minimum its causes and to search for the minimum
in the run who are searching for. But we can
optimize this by using a segment tree for example,
you can reduce the cost of searching for the
minimum and arrange to look at the recurrence
relation becomes t of n is equal to t of n
minus one plus log n, we get off n log n plus
n to build the segment tree, we've got an O of n
log n time complexity, but if n over n squared.
But we still have two solutions to discover.
The strategy we use in our first solution is dot
for each bar, we search for the next shorter bar
from the left the next shorter bar from the right,
and we calculate the area of the rectangle bar
always traversing bars again to search resulted
in an O of n squared time complexity. What if we
can traverse the histogram only wants to find the
next shorter bar of each bar? Yes, it's possible
by using a stack, we can maintain a stack and
in increasing order. For example, we have 2478,
then we want to insert five, but it wouldn't
be increasing anymore. So we'll keep popping
until we find a smaller element. And we push
it remains increasing. Then again, we'll have
six 910 12/3. To insert eight will pop 12 will
pop done, we put mine and insert, and so on.
And we can use this principle for our problem
will work with heights will maintain a stack and
to follow the next shorter bar from the left of
the actual bar who keep popping into the top of
the stack becomes shorter after it will also
push the actual bar for the next iterations.
Let me show you how it works with our example.
We can add two bars of height minus one at
extremities to avoid having an empty stack minus
one to be sure that they will be shorted at any
bar or the beginning, the stock contains
the bar zero, and will start from bar one.
The top of the stack is shorter, who already
found the next shorter is at index zero. And
we'll push the actual bar. Next index, the top
of the stack is higher Ooh pop. Now it's smaller,
the index of the next shorter is zero, and we'll
push the actual bar. Next bar top of the stack
is shorter, we already found next shorter is
the bar index two and we push the actual one.
Next bar, same thing, top of the stack
is shorter. Next bar same thing. Next
bar who performs and we find it next bar, we
have to pop all of them except the last one
because they are all higher. Next bar, the top
of the stack is all really short, its index is
seven, next bar are really shorter. And it
continues like this for the whole histogram.
Now we got the index of nav shorter
bar from the left of each bar.
But we still need the one from the right. So we
can apply the same process but from the right.
The Start Now initially contains the rightmost
bar, the one we added from there, who is the
height is minus one. First of all from the right,
the top is already shorter, and we push. Next bar
we put once and we find the index we also push
next bar already shorter. We write and we push.
Next bar, same thing we write and we push.
Next bar same thing. Next bar, same thing.
Next bar we pop twice, we write and we push
next bar, we put once we write, and we push,
next bar, we pump thrice, we write, and we
push, and the process continues like that
now for each bar, we have the index of the next
shorter bar from the left the index of the next
shorter bar from the right, we can calculate the
largest rectangle that passes from the actual bar.
For example, for this one, next
shorter bar from the left is zero.
From the right, it's seven.
So we get this rectangle
to get the largest one in the whole histogram,
whichever is largest rectangle of each bar,
while keeping track of the global largest
one, as we did in the first solution,
but we don't need to search again here. And we've
been able to solve the problem by traversing the
histogram only thrice instead of n times, which
will reduce our time complexity to O of n.
Encode who first are those two bars of height
minus one not extremities, then we create an array
from left or from left of it represents the index
of the next shorter bar from the left of the bar,
I will also create a stack that initially
contains the first bar, the one we added.
Now for each bar, except once on extremities, who
keep popping, while the bar on top of the stack
is higher, or as high as the actual bar, we write
wild heights of stock of minus one greater than or
equal to heights of oil, we pump stock of minus
one represents the top element. After the loop,
the next shorter bar from the left is on top of
the stack, we assign it to from left, I will also
push the index of the actual bar i. We finished
filling from left, who will do the same thing from
the right, acquired from right, we initialize the
stock by putting the last bar only and we start,
now we traversed bars, but in the reverse order.
Remember that we start from the right and we move.
Same logic for what's inside the loop.
But we assigned to from right of it now.
After having both arrays filled, we can start
working to initialize Max area to zero, then for
each bar, who took it who replaced Max area, Max
area becomes the maximum between its actual value
and the area of the rectangle of the actual
bar. The height of the actual bar is height
of AI. And the width is fomite of i minus from
left of i minus one minus one. Because the next
shorter bars are not included in the rectangle,
we don't count their width. So the area is height
of I times from right of i minus from left of
i minus one after the loop return max area.
For the time complexity, we have n to add those
bars and integrate from left. And now for the loop
is true that we have a nested while loop where
the total number of iterations won't exceed
and because each bar is pushed and
popped only once. And we have an bars
so the cost is N. Same logic for the process
from right, and we add on to search for Max area.
We're getting off on time complexity. And for
the space complexity we have and for heights
and for the stack, and for from left. And and for
form, right we're going off and space complexity.
In this ocean, whichever is the histogram
thrice, but we have a solution where we
traverse it only wants let's talk about it. Okay,
imagine that we have this bar as a first bar,
we can still expand it from the right because
we didn't find the shorter one. The next bar
is this one, you can still expand them both,
we found nothing that stops them. Third bar,
same thing. Fourth bar, same thing, you can still
expand them all because the hearts are increasing.
And we're putting them in a stock by the way.
Both for example, the next bar is this one,
this bar will love the previous three bars
stop expanding because it's shorter than them.
In other words, all bars that
are taller than it in the stack.
And because now we know where these bars stop,
we can't calculate the largest rectangle, the
actual bars at index four, so they stop at index
three. For this bar, here's the rectangle for the
next one of the stack. Two is the rectangle.
And for the next one, here is the rectangle.
We stopped poppin because the top of the
stack is shorter, so it can still expand.
You can see that what we're doing is that we're
pushing our bars into a stack. Then when we found
the next shorter bar from the right, we know
where they stop, we calculate their rectangle.
Now we push this point we continue this bar
Higher, we have nothing to pop without clear
push it. But for this one is shorter. So we pop
this one, and we calculate the rectangle. The
top is still taller, we pop on we calculate the
rectangle, put weight with this bar, the largest
rectangle that we can make is not this one is this
one. The reason behind this one result is that
the index of a bar is not necessarily for Maurice
largest rectangles thoughts, in reality is largest
rectangle thought form where the last
popped bar thought iterations thoughts.
For example, for this one, remember that we have
three bars, this one was the last one, it means
that the largest rectangle starts from here. This
is why when we push bar, we keep the same height,
both as index we put the index where the
rectangle of the last popped bar starts.
Let's work with a greater example, the
one we've been working with in this video,
we can add those two bars of height minus
one extremities to avoid having an empty
stack. First bar, the bar on top is shorter,
we totally put it on the stack. Next bar,
the bar on top of the stack is taller. So we
found the end of its rectangle, its Imani spawn,
the top of the stack is not small anymore, who
stopped poppin. But now when we push this bar,
as high throughput to both as index, we put the
index of the last pop bar, which is one let's
continue for is taller, we just push with
this index because we didn't pop anything.
Next bar, same thing. Next bar, same thing.
Next bar we need to pop. And we found the end
of this bar here is it's rectangle. And
when we put six as index, we put five.
Next bar, we need to pop here is the largest
rectangle of the pop the bar is beginning is
the index we pushed and is and is i minus one, we
can calculate the rectangle and see if it replaces
top is still higher, we pop top is still
higher, we pop top is still higher, we pop,
you can see that for each prompt bar, you
can easily find his largest rectangle,
top is not higher anymore, we stop. And the
starting index of the last pop node is one.
So we put an index of one when pushing the actual
bar. The reason behind it is that from the left,
our bar can extend until the index one from
the road we don't know yet. Next bar higher
without the push, next bar, same thing. And
the process continues like this until the end.
After finishing, we found the largest
rectangle is this one, we turn this area.
And we've been able to solve the problem
by traversing the histogram only once.
In code, we start by adding those bars
of extremities will create Max area,
we'll create a stack and we'll start traversing
bars. The stack initially contains the first bar,
the one that we added. And you can see that now
we're storing both the index and the height.
In the previous solution, we stole the
index only because we could calculate
the heart from the hearts array. But
this time, the pushed index is not
necessarily the one where the bar is in the
histogram. So we store both. And this time,
we need to traverse the bar of the right
extremity to empty the stack to calculate
rectangles of bars that are still in the stack.
So I start from one and goes until the last bar
at each bar, I will need a variable start that
indicates for more the largest rectangle of
the bar our thoughts. Remember, that is the
starting index of the last bar we popped.
But we didn't start popping yet. So we set it
to I now we start poppin while the bar the top
of the stack is higher or as high as the bar our
we bought, we put the index and the height into
variables. Remember that we need to calculate
the largest rectangle of the pumped bar.
It's hard is the pushed height. It's taught
index is the pushed index. And it's an index is
our minus one. So its width is i minus one minus
top index plus one, which is I'm on a stop index.
We check if it replaces Max area Max
area becomes max between its actual value
and top height times I'm on his top index.
And we're searching for the start index of
the last pop bar. So start receive stop index.
After the loop stock moves the start index of
the last popped bar and the height of the actual
bar is height of I we push start heights of AI and
after the outer loop, we're done Max area thoughts
for the time complexity, once again the inner
while loop will do a Most alliterations in total,
because each bar is pushed and popped only
once we've got an O of n time complexity,
and for the space complexity off, and
because of the stack and height array.
We've reached the end of this video. In this one,
we've seen different solutions to this problem.
I hope that you understood them all. And
that was the last problem of this course.
Congratulations for finishing this course. I hope
that you learned a lot of new things from it,
and we'll be able to apply them in all
the situations. To learn even more. You
can check the other courses I made, like the
50 popular coding interview problems course,
check the links below. Also, please tell
me what you thought about this course.
If it's good, if it's bad, what should be
improved, etc. See you in another occasion.